man I like I'm A's I remember this
because on a cart and if you touch them
it's hilarious I buy the place jeez
either way I'm gonna play me Bob up here
[Laughter]
no that doesn't work where are you where
are you trying to run around no idea
where the crappy wind I don't know this
map yet so I'm gonna used to it this is
the water change why are you what are
you I saw that I still have that where'd
you go where'd you go where'd you go I
saw you come back yeah yeah wait where's
Bob this is not a good thing to be this
is a mistake where's Bob I was
was it what you were when he killed you
no is it a blue trashcan no I thought
you were on the other side oh so you try
to go grab one of those plushies where's
where's that other trashcan I don't know
there's a + c f-- running away Pharaoh I
heard a shaky scoop oh man I missed you
missed what's going on here you scared
that was you Wayne yeah oh my god you
scared the bejesus out of me don't worry
Bob I'll run into you sooner or later
oh you can become that that's what I am
next time what I found my prop Oh God
I'm back into spawn as big as I thought
it was bigger whoa what no what what huh
[Laughter]
I'm like a [ __ ]
shut up like a [ __ ] I was doing is
going around like a jack inator getaway
but I did thank you for today is turtle
rocks - do you mean slab of meat
[Laughter]
that would have been beautiful if you
had no run right into me yeah whatever
oh well oh no oh oh I can just fly
through the level yeah yeah if you press
space you can free up why oh I found you
mark you did
am i close to wait no I don't care about
your input anymore literally you could
not possibly be I'm trying to help
you're not no liar you're a liar we're
kind of comically far away from him Wow
that go the wrong way he's moving I
don't know it's it's I had to run you do
but run towards me I don't know where
you are
oh you moved it you moved it I got you
he was moving the whole time the
direction that I was moving shake it
like a Polaroid picture uh no no I'm oh
I guess that's still a brand name is
that okay
I I don't know not sponsored by Kodak or
Cola don't know oh god oh god oh god
don't give me I'm a comment for you I
don't think you are these suits talk
like a Swedish round are you playing
Skyrim ago that's an order saying is
this how Skyrim is I think it is
goodness I can't believe you can't hide
[Music]
[Laughter]
where you be at I'm coming for you I
just need to know which way you're gonna
go so I don't run into you I didn't say
what I said we're in the counter-strike
map hi oh okay wait I thought we were
running around I am running around he's
in the dark running in a little tiny
square no I've moved all around the map
the video evidence will show that I was
moving on the road map I'm following
someone bunch of stuff around up here
yeah I was thrown everything everywhere
well that helps you go where'd you guys
go you want to come and play
I guess he's chasing you Wade I don't
know where'd you guys go I actually lost
you where'd you go I go run I don't know
mark why don't you run out in the open
why don't you
Oh
[Music]
we've set forth on our journey to the
available shopping Mart of slow drive do
those I don't know what what do you mean
are you trying to do that thing where
you try and sing up a well-known a
popular oh I don't even know what you
were doing there no no no the speedway
song in the world you're talking about
you can just beep it out beep out that
whole thing work for me swear words and
you're gonna have to beat them out
because they're gonna be so scary
something
banana farts Apple bag puncher monkey